right just as an extraordinary meeting
of council the purpose for this today is
to uh confirm what we've already
discussed earlier on today which was the
outcomes we came to
um have the extraordinary finance and
projects committee
um
just a little background before we get
into the meeting wouldn't normally like
to run two meetings like this because it
takes away the ability for people to
have a second thought but it was really
important that we give some certainty to
the community
about where we're going and also to abl
that have got the contract
um currently paused out of tearsbury so
just work our way through that
um
oh yes so before I get to that I just
need to confirm that we've got an
apology from Alex who is a member of
this committee seconded thank you
and on to the um recommendations from
the finance and projects committee and
you'll notice that there were seven of
those
um
it's a move we received as a major late
item
thank you
thank you again good to have the same
two doing both times
um so we just uh we'll have the seven
recommendations up
and there they are
so before we get to voting on that if
there's any issues that people would
like to raise now it's the time
there's none I'll give you
nodule chance as lead to do a short
speech on this given that Aaron's got to
be away in 10 minutes
a couple of reflections
I just want to acknowledge actually the
work that has been done in previous
times so I think that's incredibly
important it's not about the small the
group that's worked tirelessly in the
last four or five weeks it's actually
about a whole history of folk that have
worked over a long long period of time
to to in a dream into reality really and
it has taken time but I think
um I had to applaud the current Council
and the vision that they've had and the
faith they've had in our
in our team to achieve what they've done
in a very short space of time but
enormous amount of work that's been put
in over a long period of time so we
shouldn't forget that at all
but what we have done we're going to
create a bit of a legacy and this
council is and I think we should all be
very proud of that come 1225 when we
have a shell up and we should we
shouldn't forget that but also the
protection of that storage facility and
of our heritage is incredibly important
to me I know Evelyn I think that was we
would would have been remiss if we
didn't do that
for our community and and what we have
so I think we've done two really good
jobs today as a team and uh
we look I really look forward to the
challenge that we all have together and
it is going to be a challenge no
question but we take it head on I know
from our Communications it's incredibly
important and that's what we have to do
exceptionally well from now through to
12 the end of 12 25 is that we tell the
story we be open and honest with the
public right throughout that process and
we share with them the steps that we
take in the development of the projects
we we continue to share on a regular
basis and we get them involved and we
have open days we have some recognition
on the site what's going to happen and
we get them involved where we can
and we you all get involved as well
where we can
it's incredibly exciting like I the CBD
is exciting but this next phase for
invercargill South and Incredibly
exciting I can't be more excited so do
want to acknowledge once again though
the work of the team
um all of the team because it's been a
big big ask so let's get this damn thing
built
yeah look I've got a question about
um obviously what what is going to be
inside the visitor experience and that's
really what makes it are we gonna are we
gonna slowly update the public as that
design comes to fruition or are we gonna
hold it back
so that it's a big surprise you know you
first go in then boom is it is it how
how are we going to do that yeah I'll
just talk Brie Brit and I'll swing to
Aaron so the vision we haven't at the
moment we've all talked about it over
time is that we need to be Innovative no
question we need to be creative and we
need we need to use it no no but I
always gotta release it to the public
isn't it by bet or we're gonna save it
to to to to bang opening day and wow
well there's two ways of doing that
we've done it with different projects in
the sense of and what we want to achieve
I the communities on board the community
as of five o'clock is going to be on
board with us no question it's how much
information we give them and we whether
you want to have that wealth Factor the
total well Factor uh come 12 20 into 12
25 well we share them we share a bit of
the journey we certainly wouldn't tell
every story we might give some Snippets
I don't even I'll look to you in a
minute but from my perspective from a
media and a marketing point of view we
need to control it
but we need to also add excitement a
little bit like the CBD CBD we did in
the sense of process but bring them on
the journey with us but we don't they
don't get too much so there's
anticipation anticipation it's about
going with to your first ball really
with your first partner
that was a great occasion for me to be
honest
that was a wonderful occasion Erin over
to you
I'm not quite sure how to follow that
well you would wear a beautiful ball
gown I'm sure the only piece that I'll
add to that is that we will be working
through who we need in terms of
community stakeholders to be involved in
in that process with us to make sure
that we are getting that key input and
bringing people on the journey through
the development of the museum experience
as the project progresses
and I think Wayne's already been doing
some public
um stakeholder meetings we want a bit of
words looking at what's potentially
there on the inside the experience which
has been for those that have been here
rang and I have both been recently
um really exciting
but again
um
it's it's really hard to visit what they
would be while you're still looking at
the building I guess yeah Darren uh it's
really possible if you design a space to
design exhibits to fit around it I know
that the first iteration was criticized
for
um telling showing people the building
and not necessarily what was going to be
inside but really with modern
storytelling techniques it is
a hugely flexible process and and once
the designs are finalized work on
preparing those exhibitions can start
straight away yeah so that they are
ready to be installed
um in 126 and that's a process that
would take obviously several months but
the design of exhibitions is something
that can be synchronous with the
construction of the project once the
designs are finalized right yeah I
wasn't going to play this cab but back
in 2012 and well before I had media
training
um
I got interviewed by by even Harding it
was quite a good one uh
for some reason he asked me about the
museum and and I said well I wouldn't go
because it's like watching paint dry or
grass growing and of course that that
hit the media and
and uh there was about a hundred odd 150
odd reply you know those comments down
below 86 percent of them agreed with me
that that back then the museum had lost
it its impact
the only beneficial thing to me that
came out of that was chicane did a
cartoon of tutuatara looking at the
pyramid one saying you act like grass
growing and I'll act like paint drying
Here Comes counselor pottinger yeah so
I'm just very weary of of the need for
this something happening inside because
I believe that back it had lost it had
lost you know it's it's pink
so we've done a lot of work in a just in
casual conversation but one of the
things I think uh Mr gibbling may have
said this is not going to be a rainy day
Museum
this is not going to be a rainy day
Museum this is going to be an everyday
Museum this is where people are going to
come along on a Monday Tuesday Wednesday
not a weekend Museum but an everyday
Museum so we've talked about it we're
going to focus on the Innovative we're
going to talk about the inside what's
inside the museum Innovative creative
multi-purpose multifunctional spaces we
can turn upside down inside out whatever
to make exhibitions whatever we were
doing to fit spaces but it has to be and
it has to we have to Future proof we
have to Future proof we have to change
it up
for the next generation and the one
Beyond so technology in my opinion and
I'm sure in the in the league team's
opinion will be a key to their overall
success
to the to the Museum somebody in the
final comment um yeah is that all these
other things were voted on are very
tangible we've got pricing we've got
timelines everything like that we can
see that we can approve it we've looked
at the risks but the only thing that we
can't come to grips with is what we're
going to get on the inside and we we've
got great faith it will happen but it's
it's that's the bit that
that really uh I guess you know it's
going to happen we're going to see
something sometime oh absolutely and
we've got to tell it's a story and it's
an evolving story it's a we've got a
wonderful wonderful story to tell about
invercargill South and there's a
terrific story it's a journey we're
going to go on and it's just how we
portray it both visually technology wise
and with static that that's the
combination we're looking at even you
might want to add a little bit there do
you or
not particularly however I will say that
I think not to put the cart before the
horse we don't have a building yet
um until we have a design it's really
hard to say what
even though what councilor Scout says is
true it's about what media we use and
how we use the space and all those sorts
of things the the nuts and bolts of the
story is there but what media is used to
portray that story and will that be the
same on Tuesday as it was on Saturday
because with technology that's what you
can do
um
I think that
it's it's really hard I understand what
you say about wanting to generate the
interest and what the inside will be but
I remember when to Papa opened and I
think the first thing was just the
stunning visuals of what the ceremonial
was and all the rest of it when we got
over that and we went inside and saw the
different things so these stages of
marketing something like this if you
give too much away of what is going to
be inside do you build that anticipation
how do you keep the balance but the
other thing is I would caution against
the idea that a council table is the
right place to design what the content
of the internet we're not designing it
as long as we're we're not thinking that
that here is the place to make the final
decision because I don't
necessarily think that we might get what
your expectation might be
yeah Peter
I've got you grant thank you very much
yeah it's great
very exciting indeed a lot of people in
the last few years for ideas of having
the museum and the
in in the city center but
uh looking at their Sony place for
there's you know 280 odd car parks and
close proximity
and that I mentioned at a workshop about
parking for the disabled and that was
addressed I think there's about 14 or 16
car parks there
um
and I'm so pleased that the Tuatara are
going to be in the main Museum even
though less of them uh
could I ask a question like there was
200 square meters previously set aside
for the existing tuataris uh what's the
space now and as the minders of the
tuatara
happy with the new area
is that Mr gibbling
through you uh Mr chair
um councilor
the spaces
um slightly bigger than what we've
currently allocated uh currently
allocated in the existing pyramid
facility the team are currently going
through the design work at the moment
and we're engaging with the
respective Partners through Doc and the
Tuatara Collective that look after the
Tuatara which includes naito and
natikuato Etc
thank you and one further question with
a new build we're going to have a lot
lot more visitors to the museum
uh as the I know the current uh kitchen
that we had there in dining area
uh around the cafeteria is that going to
be larger than the previous one
a three-year game Mr chair
um councilor I think we're based on the
previous spatial configurations which on
very early stages uh the idea of that
public space which included the retail
and Cafe
would be better designed because it
would be a designed and an entirely new
facility and so those spaces will be a
lot more appropriate and more flexible
and will have a greater indoor outdoor
flow connecting directly into Queen's
Park so I expect that space will be a
lot better than it was previously yeah
that was sort of an add-on because in
the early days of the museum there was
no cafeteria
okay yeah thank you grant I was just
gonna do some sponges concerns around
you know we've got a worldcast stadium
World cast out of drone we've got a
fantastic new CBD two great motorcycle
museums and truck museums and so you
know I back ourselves to have a
fantastic
um Museum that represents Southland and
I think that's a key part of it as well
as we you know we tell the story across
Southland and we encourage southlanders
to enjoy it so certainly come on
trash
I think we just got to remember the
passion and this is going to be a real
excitement but many of the museums that
I've visited here and around the world I
go to regularly I might be in a place
for a week and go every day to the same
Museum because it's got so much to offer
and that's what I'm looking for in our
Museum I'd love to think that you want
to go every day because it was too much
the first time so we've got to keep that
passion and Innovative dream big to make
it to something really exciting yep
I think some Mr Mia I was just going to
say on the matter of the interior
um I I do think we need to always
remember that hopefully in about 10
minutes time we're going to make a um
Milestone decision about actually not
drawing a Line in the Sand but
figuratively pouring the first of the
concrete yeah
um
we are going to provide the F4 in 1225
a building in which we can have exciting
new exhibitions and we have to remember
that we have a staff who are going to be
able and now after their decision are
going to be empowered to start thinking
about exactly how you put those exciting
exhibitions together because we know we
have a great collection and we have
spent a great deal of time now
cataloging that collection and getting
it to the point where you can start
thinking about the exciting ways of
displaying it so I don't think we have
to concentrate too much at all on the
interior except to say as we have all
along that we do want it to be
Innovative exciting groundbreaking and
for the future in using technology in
new ways I I think without making it too
obvious that we actually need to confirm
our our decisions so that we do have not
a Line in the Sand which can always be
moved but the figurative first pouring
of concrete that we have actually today
made the absolutely final decision 12 25
is going to happen
and we move forward and we therefore do
Empower our staff to start thinking the
reality is we can from tomorrow if
they're not already doing it start
thinking about the ways in which the
building we're going to produce can be
used to have those exciting exhibitions
displayed but let's not forget we employ
very expert staff members
to deliver those they're not they're not
heirs as the governors to say we want
this or that on display or whatever
um it's us who's setting the policy to
say what we want is the Innovative
exciting displays of air of their
brilliant collection
and it's remiss of me not to have
mentioned it earlier but could we delete
the reference to the existing pyramid
site and make it the existing Museum
site it isn't a pyramid
it's a museum
um the the shell was supposed to denote
the tooth
of um the tanifa niho to tanifa and I do
recognize that in common parlance around
the city it is called referred to as the
pyramid but it is actually the museum
um
if the others agree I would prefer that
that wording was changed sure because
this again is a legacy that we are
leaving
Foreigner so that they understood
or they understand where 1225 comes from
it comes from this
thank you Mr just a final asking you Tom
sorry I my comment is going to be a
little bit retro I'm afraid I mean I
think when we talk about you know the
display in in terms of You Know audio
visual and interactive and so forth we
should remember that we've got a
collection which would be you know the
Envia suspects of probably most cities
in New Zealand and people do want to see
physical things I mean I know they kind
of touch them usually but they do want
to see physical things rather than you
know I mean if it's only artificial it
might as well be taken Cameron's tomb
because you could you could do that so I
I I I mean you know as we get to talk
about this stuff I guess my plea would
be that we don't forget that we really
should be putting the rotating it but we
should be putting the collection on
display
yeah
so just a reflection of that
um when we had our uh recent session
with Wayne Merritt we talked about that
about the old organ Island slash
Antarctic display they've had in the old
Museum
um where everything you went through it
just had signs that say Don't touch
don't touch and every kid that went up
just spun the wheel anyway and so we we
talked about you know you don't have to
have the historic wear off a ship of 100
years ago you can just put one up that
replicates it and the kids can actually
have the touch and feel type thing
um look I've uh listen to what Lee had
to say earlier on about um
do you build a complex and then fit in
your experience will you do it the other
way around and I think what we've done
already is that we've started to do it
the other way around we've explored what
we want to have by way of experience and
then it'll be up to the in the design
process for people like uh Wayne married
to have some input into what sort of
space he will need to deliver that which
will then lead on to the design step for
those who can cast your mind back about
a year ago we had a
a think tank independent group that came
in that had blue Sands in it and if you
went listen to his presentation
um when that was all done and dusted um
it was fantastic the stories that he
could tell about about certain things
I'd never even heard of
um so there's a great wealth of uh
history and storytelling to be done and
but in a positive way that it's not just
standing so um
if somebody would like to move that
references to the pyramid I'd change to
the museum that would be great I don't
have any other thing to do Institute
would change that yeah
so it doesn't need moving okay okay so
the uh the last issue for me is to go
around the room as opposed to having a
formal vote and just ask people uh which
of the two options they prefer so those
people who are live streaming and
haven't caught there earlier uh
extraordinary meeting we had we we faced
two options plan a which is to uh
um continue with the story facility at
Tisbury and demolish the
um the current Museum sometimes referred
to as a pyramid and
um and build on that site which avoided
any need to change the classification
further down
the second option which is Plan B
um involved leaving the collection where
it was
um potentially canceling tillsbury with
some economic Savings in that but we
would have to move down the land that
was available to us by the pyramid or
the old Museum which would take some
um reclassification of the reserve
status and that potentially could hold
us up for quite some time so
one thing would be sort of helpful just
to go around the room and make sure that
everybody's on to the same plan options
to plan a and plan B so Peter
A or B
A or B yeah hey hey ringy yeah a
definitely Tom plenty yep I don't know
no no play night all right hey
in this way accepting it that our EU
representative has already indicated
plainly plan I it is the far superior
outcome and me too
oh yeah sorry
that makes sense
so Nigel that's uh you know this fight
well done people
so does that cover off the
recommendations would you would you like
it move oh yeah I suppose yeah
and Leslie's sitting there all those in
favor
not against thinking
if we just now move to close the meeting
move that yeah
yeah
signal Barry all those in favor
oh
yeah